- What I want to talk about
is work I've done in...
Yeah, inferring nature,
in physics, biology,
and using machine learning.
And to keep things interesting,
I'm applying to phrase the conversation
as if it's a match
between humans and nature,
where humans score points
when they infer something new about nature
and nature scores points when
it's making it harder for us
and trying to to keep us at bay.
So yeah, so you might think
that since everybody here,
so I'm talking to people,
some might think that be
we would be team human,
but even ancient Greece where
the skeptics that maintain
that nature cannot be known.
So maybe even in the
audience there's like this...
Like different teams.
Excellent, so we started with
this fundamental question,
what are the fundamental laws?
The fundamental axioms of the universe?
And the thing is that we don't know.
We don't know and this is depressing
because we start being very ambitious,
and trying to kick off the project
of inferring nature off the ground.
But there is no ground,
there is no bedrock
upon which to build systematically
and trying to infer the rest of nature.
This is in stark contrast with mathematics
where we have axioms that we postulate,
and then we take for granted as bedrock
and we start inferring.
Alex was very nicely explaining
how there are some prerequisites
for picking those axioms,
but then we use them as given,
whereas we don't have that in science.
There's no bedrock, it's more like a swamp
that you're trying to
bootstrap yourself out of.
So why do I say that we don't have
the fundamental axioms of the universe?
It's because experiments suggest
that there are four forces
that describe interaction
of matter with other matter,
electromagnetism, the
strong nuclear force,
the weak nuclear force, and gravity.
And the first three have been unified
in a common framework that we call
the standard model of particle physics.
But the fourth one
hasn't been incorporated
into a common framework.
This is why we don't have
the axioms because we cannot,
in a unified framework,
describe everything.
And the reason for that is ultimately
how they deal with information.
The first three forces
explicitly preserve information,
whereas the fourth force,
at least on face value,
seems to destroy it.
And since you can't have
both simultaneously,
it's very hard to put them together.
And it's very hard to put them together
but it's not like string
theorists have given up
and they have been trying to resolve
this information paradox
first introduced by Hawking,
coincidentally was in
previous PhD committee.
And what they have figured out lately,
as of five years ago,
is that information seems
to be lost in our universe
because of the presence of baby universes
that constantly split off of our universe
and then merge back onto it.
And if you take into account those effects
of universes splitting off of ours
and merging to this one,
you can actually reproduce this effect
that information seems to be lost
because you only have
access to one universe.
And there was a paper, a similar paper
by Maxfield and Marolf in 2020
and also our paper from last year
that, yeah, reproduces this effect.
So in our paper we used
topological quantum gravity,
so we had the regular gravity
you have in our universe
and we unified it and reproduced,
resolved Hawking's Paradox.
Not with these three forces
that I'm showing there
but with another force which was described
by topological quantum
field theory so we did...
So in this model, which is rigorous
and analytically exactly computable model,
you had a common framework
where we accept gravity
and non-gravitational forces,
and you are resolving
the information paradox.
But so there is a lot of
progress I'm trying to say,
but still we unify gravity
with a completely random other force,
not with these three so still,
we don't have the fundamental axioms.
And you might say that, "Oh, that's bad."
But now I'm doing computational biology,
so we don't need to...
We don't need gravity for that.
And if I'm saying that we understand
the first three forces nearly perfectly,
then why not make a simulation?
Oh, by the way, yeah, so
this lack of laws of physics
is how nature keeps us at bay
and poses the first challenge,
nobody gives us the
axioms of of the universe.
But like I was saying,
we don't need gravity
so how about doing the following thing
like discretizing space
and putting the standard
model of particle physics
on that discretized space
and then try to perfectly simulate a cell.
That would be super cool
because then we would be able
to find initial particle
configuration in the cell,
then simulate a drug coming in
and seeing exactly what effect would have.
So we'd be able to have initial
calculate drugs and stuff.
So can we perfectly simulate a cell?
And of course there's nothing
particular about the cell.
Can we simulate the universe
or parts of it perfectly?
And unfortunately there's a theorem
that says that you cannot do that.
It's the Nielsen-Ninomiya theorem
and more precisely it says,
that you cannot simulate
the standard portal...
The standard model of particle physics
in on a discretized space.
And since the standard
model of particle physics
is our universe that means
that you can't simulate the universe.
The proof of that relies in two ideas.
The idea is...
The first idea is that the standard model
has chiral particles, which means that
when the particle
rotates, spins like this,
it can move in only one of two directions,
either this way or or the opposite way.
And you call this right-handed
and this left-handed.
Yeah, so those are the
only two possibilities
that it allows.
And in fact, it's
interesting that it picks...
Prefers the right-hand...
The left-handed particles
but tho those are the
only two possibilities.
And the second idea is something
that we learn in undergrad physics,
that when you have discretized
space, momentum is periodic.
That means that identical...
Like that values of the momentum
periodically are completely equivalent.
Using those two ideas, you can prove
that the standard model
of particle physics
cannot exist in discretized space.
Because if you have a particle,
right-hand particle like that,
then this positive momentum
since we're in discretized space,
would be completely
equivalent to being negative.
But that means that this particle
will be both left-handed and right-handed.
But the so there molecule part...
So the model that treats
those particles differently,
which is an absurd and
(indistinct) absurd,
and we prove that this
cannot be happening.
So, there's another way to look at this.
So this answers the question
of whether we live in the matrix
as Professor David Tong
from Trinity College
likes to phrase it.
If we cannot simulate the universe,
then this indeed could
not be a simulation.
We cannot be living in the matrix
because then CERN wouldn't be giving
the data results that it is giving us.
Yeah, however, it's nice to say that...
It's comforting that
what I'm experiencing is not a simulation
but from a scientific point
of view it's depressing.
It's another point for nature
because we cannot have perfect simulations
of the fundamental laws
as we understand them.
Oops...
Oh, yeah so we don't know
the axioms of the universe.
Even when we do know them,
we cannot perfectly simulate them.
What's left then?
Well clearly, what's
left is to do experiments
but they come with their own issues.
And in particular all of analyzing data
because the moment you get your data,
you have to analyze
them and interpret them,
and then you run into the
generalizability problem,
which of course is like a cylinder.
If you look at it from the top,
it manifests in different ways
depending on your perspective
and yeah, even in philosophy,
people have looked into that, right?
Even in ancient Greece, Sextus Empiricus,
David Hume that we heard about.
Also the rule following,
I like to think of
as this Generalizability Problem.
And yeah, so it consists of
the following thought experiment.
If you like have an apple and you drop it,
you see it fall to the ground.
And if you report that a
hundred times it keeps happening
but are you allowed the 101st time
to conclude that it surely
will be like the previous ones
that it'll fall to the ground?
In other words, generalizability
is about arguing
from observed cases,
based on observed cases,
about unseen cases.
And in machine learning we're
interested in those cases
when the unseen cases, we know are priori
that they're bound to different a bit.
And yeah, so that's why I call it
Out Of Distribution prediction
or as of late, in the context
of foundational models,
we refer to it as zero-shot learning.
Yeah, so and in that
context so in general,
if we know if we allow the unseen cases
to be arbitrarily different
than the seen cases,
then clearly we cannot possibly conclude
something about them.
We can not conclude something
about what you haven't observed.
And this is the...
This goes by the name essentially
of the no free lunch theorem.
What it says more specifically
is that an algorithm
can only be better at finding
a data generating distribution
only at the expense of being
worse at finding another one,
at inferring another one.
So alternative algorithm
A will on average,
have the same performance
than any other algorithm
when you average above
across all problems.
Yeah, so this is the final...
Another point for nature,
which is leading by now by three points.
So how are we pushing back against
this generalizability problem?
What can we do about this issue?
Well, what we can do about it is...
What comes to the rescue
is using constraints
from prior knowledge,
that's the way to get off.
So what general...
What the no free lunch theorem introduces
is this trade off between
bias and variants.
The way to get rid of it,
is to introduce prior
knowledge constraints.
And the way to do that is to
start gathering a lot of data
and start noticing patterns.
For instance, you can impose the pattern
that your model has to have sparsity
and therefore datasets
that could not be produced
by sparse models would be rejected.
And that would allow your algorithm A,
to over to over perform other algorithms
in the relevant cases that
haven't been excluded.
But of course in biology,
we're trying to push
further ahead from that
and that's what the Human
Cell Atlas tries to do.
instead of just using sparsity.
We're introducing, we're compiling
very comprehensive data sets
of both observational
and interventional data
across many organs diseases, donors,
both for single cell and also spatially.
I'm not sure if this has a pointer
but like here you can see
that now we know that...
What genes are expressed in this point
versus what other genes are expressed
in this other point of
this section of the tissue.
I should also say that
the Human Cell Atlas
is Co-Led by Professor Sarah
Teichmann and Aviv Regev.
And it's this effort of trying to map
all the different cell types
that exist in the human body
because although all the cells in my body
have the same exactly genome,
they make different choices.
And the cell in my eye
decides to be an eye cell
and the cell on my skin, a skin cell.
So they decide to focus on
different parts of the genome
and undergo what we refer
to as differentiation.
And in order to understand
better human health and disease,
we're trying to map out all
the different possibilities
that cells have to opt for.
Yeah, so that's how we push back.
We start gathering now
biological prior knowledge
and build models based on that
and that's how we start
pushing back against nature
by compiling though this
is a very big consortium
and a huge effort in single cell biology.
And furthermore, in my work in progress
in the Lotfollahi Lab,
we're building this Dis2p model,
which stands for disentangle covariates
to predict counterfactuals.
And it lies at the intersection
between disentangled learning,
fairness, and causality.
And our DA is that during
the training process,
we augment the data by matching
that up with one another
to produce counterfactual pairs.
And then during the training process,
we constantly do the three steps
of abduction, action, and prediction,
and penalize the training process.
So during the training process,
we're trying to predict counterfactuals
and make a model that
predicts them better.
Yeah, in order to have
a better performance
for out of distribution prediction.
Another thing, what comes to the rescue
about not knowing the fundamental
axioms of the universe
is another idea from theoretical physics,
which is the renormalization group.
And which essentially says that phenomena
at different length scales
are siloed from one another.
They don't get...
So phenomena at the subatomic level
are not relevant for phenomena
at much larger length scales.
Yeah, more precisely what
it says is that a theory
that tries to explain a phenomena
at a specific length scale
should be phrased with degrees of freedom
that are in the same length scale.
And in that way, that
theory will manage...
We will manage to have it
be elegant and have it be...
Need a finite number of measurements
in order to be predicted.
Yeah, so imagine like in the
context of a disease spreading
clearly the relevant degrees
of freedom to capture
would be the bacteria and the where...
Like discovered by Robert Koch.
And then we would be able
to build a nice theory
of how disease spreads.
Clearly we could also try to do it
with subatomic degrees of freedom
but we would put a huge
monster that could do it
but it wouldn't be any better in doing so
than if we had used the
right degrees of freedom.
Because ultimately our immense success
in designing drugs and
understanding biology,
tells us that the tiny details
in which gravity is quantized,
in this way or in another
slightly different way,
couldn't possibly matter.
That's what this theorem,
The Renormalization Group tells us.
At the other extreme, you could try...
Think of trying to explain how
disease spreads by using...
Not allowing yourself to
use the notion of bacteria
and build a theory solely
at the people's level.
And you don't have to
think to imagine that
because in medieval Europe
that's exactly what people were doing.
They were using this now debunked theory
about how diseases spread,
the miasma theory invented
by ancient Greek physicians.
Miasma in Greek means a pollutant.
They were thinking of it as a cloud
that settles upon the town
and causes people to suffer,
and then that cloud arbitrarily decides
to move to the next town over.
And yeah, they had built
this theory, which was...
You could...
If you do it with confounders,
you could make it be predictive.
They put the Pope...
They surrounded the Pope with
fire and that protected him
but it was clear because it
was keeping the sick people out
and not any weird cloud groups.
Yeah, so you could also
build a theory like that
but you would have to
constantly keep modifying it
based on weird confounders
and weird patterns that arise
because you have to
captured the real things.
And that is another thing that rescues us,
to do biology, I don't need to simulate
the standard model of particle physics
like you have suspected.
And indeed so in biology,
most of the time we end up using...
Most of our problems are combinatorial.
They have to do about molecules
and concentrations of the
molecules in solutions.
But we don't need to
simulate atomic dynamics,
sometimes molecular but most of the time
it's combinatory problems and for those
you can reliably use simulations.
For instance, in this other work on
the package EmptyDrops, we had the...
There is a following
very important problem
in computational biology.
So right now in biology we can figure out,
like I was telling you,
different cells opt for different choices,
combination of genes to express.
So, it's important to be able to sequence
and figure out what genes
each cell expresses.
And in order to do that,
you have to capture the cell
and count all the molecules in it.
But sometimes you're trying
to capture it and you miss
and you capture next to it solution,
like yeah water with some
RNA and DNA molecules
in that random water that you...
Because those molecules leaked from cells
or nuclei into the water.
So sometimes you capture the cell
and sometimes you don't
but you think you have
because you still capture the RNA
and that risks confounding
downstream analysis
because sometimes you have noise
and you can mistake it to be a real cell,
and then start imagining
that you have a new cell type
so it's a huge problem
in computational biology.
And there are some
methods to deal with that.
For instance, there is
this famous algorithm
that we use in computational biology,
it's called CellRanger and it says that,
"Oh come on, if you capture noise,
it must be so much less than a real cell
that has a lot of RNA and DNA in it."
So I'm just gonna say
that all the observations
that have a lot of RNA
and DNA are real cells,
all the other ones are just noise.
But of course if the signal to
noise ratio starts being bad,
you cannot make the distinction.
And yeah, so what if you have a cell
that has as much RNA as the noise,
then clearly you are either gonna have
too many false positives
or false negatives.
You need a better method to do it.
And our idea was to go in the observations
that have very few RNA and DNA molecules.
So if it has 10 RNA
molecules that must be noise,
there's no cell with
just 10 RNA molecules.
So great, so those are surly noise.
And then if you put all of this together,
you can create a profile of the noise
and then you can go in the cases
where indeed they are ambiguous.
And so here's how many
DNA molecules you have
and here how many RNA molecules you have
so in these ambiguous ones
that are in the middle
and you don't know, which they are,
since you have profiled the noise,
you can do a statistical hypothesis test
whether the observation
is statistically close
to the distribution you
created for the noise.
And if they deviate, you
think of them as cells
that was our idea, which doesn't make
personality assumptions
about the expected cells.
And indeed in the simulation
we show that we're doing a
lot better than CellRanger
because so, what we did in the simulation
is we took a data set that
processed by CellRanger,
CellRanger thinks that
the red ones are cells
and the black ones are not cell.
And we took a thousand observations
of the ones it thinks our cells
and we downs sampled the
number of counts in each one.
So to simulate a small cell,
which should be realistic
because it's like a reductio
ad absurdum again, right?
So I'm saying that, "Oh okay,
competitor, I agree with you
and you are right then
let's down sample that."
Then you can see here
that CellRanger does miss
the green population of small
cells, whereas we find it
because those, that
small cell still has...
Is statistically different than the noise.
Yeah...
So...
Yeah, excellent and in other projects
in the Dachman Lab, we're focusing
on the following very
important problem, which is,
so in multicellular organisms
in order to function
and since by definition
they have many cells,
those many different cells
need to coordinate their activities.
For instance, in my eyes see something,
the rest of my body
needs to potentially go
in a fight or flight mode,
so they need to communicate
the signal that my eyes got.
So, there's this need of
cellular communication
and how they communicate...
At least one of the ways
they can communicate
is by the sending cell
excreting a molecule
that we call the ligand,
that ligand moving on
until it reaches the receiving cell
that has another molecule on its surface
that we call the receptor
and it activates the receptor
and causes something
inside the receiving cell.
However, some receptors are orphan
in the sense that we don't
know any endogenous...
Any ligands that bind them
yet they're at very conspicuous
places, for instance,
in the part of the
heart that makes it pump
or in the brain and
conserved across species.
So they're not useless,
they're being used,
we just don't know how.
And that for one thing makes us
not know enough fundamental biology
for another thing creates
potential side effects
that we don't understand for drugs
because they potentially
activate those receptors.
And yeah, also like in designing new drugs
that would potentially want
to activate those receptors,
would be important to find
which ligands activate them.
And of course this has been
done, has been attempted
with protein structure
looking at the molecules
and trying to see how they fit together.
But our idea is to use
spatial genomic data sets,
for instance, what I showed there.
And since we now know at
each spot in this section,
in this image, what genes
are expressed at this spot,
we developed a hypothesis test
and we see that ligands are receptors
tend to be co-expressed.
So, the ligand is expressed
where there is a receptor to hear it.
So nature in sense is not
wasteful in communicating.
It doesn't express a ligand
in a location where it'll be useless
because there wouldn't be
any receptor to hear it.
Kind of like a tree falling in a forest
where there's nobody to hear
it, that doesn't happen.
Yeah, they are called called co-localized,
they're nearby neighbors.
So right now we're
developing a generating model
for trying to find gene programs
shared between between cells.
Yeah so, and in doing so they'll be able
to capture those ligand receptor pairs.
So gene programs define
the identity of a cell,
like I was saying, there's an eye program
that makes those eyes
in my eye, eye cells.
But there's also those shared gene program
that capture those
interactions between cells
and that's what we're doing right now.
And yeah, that's scores and another point
and now we're tied with nature.
And yeah, so in summary, this
went by faster than I thought,
I don't know why but yeah,
in summary like EmptyDropsMultiome,
we developed this package
for powerful and accurate cell calling.
This needs to be for casual
model of covariate effects
on genomic information
and cell communication
for energy for de-orphanizing receptors.
And yeah, I would like
to thank the labs in,
and we are such a great team.
Of course, I'm sure
we'll score another point
and put humanity ahead.
So yeah, thanks so much.
(audience applauds)
- Thanks, Stathis that's
very, very interesting.
So I'm gonna take the prerogative
and ask the first question.
So, one is a comment and then a question.
I mean there are
fundamental laws in nature,
we just don't know all of them.
- Right, right, right.
- I mean it's not...
It's an incomplete set.
- Yeah.
- So, okay.
And then I just wanted to clarify, right?
So the thinking on the information paradox
has evolved quite a lot.
So I think Hawking himself
kind of changed his mind
as, you know, towards the end, right?
So he had a very nice analogy,
which I repeat quite often,
but I think it's instructive
is that suppose you have
the Encyclopedia Britannica
and you look up New Haven and you know,
a hundred thousand people
population, whatever.
Then you put that encyclopedia in a box,
so it's printed, we read it,
you know, we read the information,
then you put that in a
closed box, you burn it down.
So then, but all the ashes
from the burning of this are
contained within that box,
so nothing is left the system.
So what's really, maybe the way
to think about the information paradox
is that we just no longer know
how the information is stored
in that ash and we do not know
how to extract information from that ash.
So the fact that the inter
information may be there,
but just coded in a way that
we do not have access yet,
might be an interesting
way to think about it.
Because as you know, in
the context of black holes,
where that paradox is brought up.
Now we believe that there
are potential resolutions
to the paradox, right?
- The most promising is this
island conjecture prompted.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Those be the university.
- It is, yes.
- But we're also...
I should probably let
you finish the question.
- No, we should...
No, no, but that was just a note.
I mean we can discuss that offline,
but I was curious in one of the vignettes
that you presented of experimental
work and simulation work,
so what are the attributes that are used
to define cell versus non-cell?
So in...
So these are the
simulations in single cell.
Yeah here, single cell biology.
- So, the attributes...
So what do you mean by attributes?
- Oh, how do you...
What is differentiates a
cell from a non-cell, right?
You mentioned that.
- So yeah...
So it's this idea that like,
yeah, a cell should not be damaged
so it should be very well preserved.
And yeah, trying to see
whether you captured
a well preserved cell or
you capture just something-
- [Moderator] So the
non-cell is just a failure?
- Yeah, a failure.
- [Moderator] Oh okay, sorry.
- Yeah, so we're trying to
capture it, trying to fish it.
- [Moderator] Okay.
- And we just captured some
solution with RNA in it.
- [Moderator] Okay, okay, okay thanks.
- Yeah, so it's like mechanistic-
- Oh it's-
- What makes it...
- Yeah, whether it's intact or not, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- The information is intact.
Okay, great so that was just
a point of clarification.
Questions?
- I have a question about your discussion
of siloing at different scales.
And this is actually drawing on an example
from Eric Winsberg who
spoke in the project.
But as this appeared, where...
And I'm curious whether
you see this as consistent
with the kinds of support
of you were making.
He was looking at a
material science project
that was working on
semiconductor materials
and it gets segregated
in different scales.
So where you have fractures and the bonds,
you use quantum mechanical models.
And at slightly larger scales,
you use classical molecular dynamics
and then different models
and still larger scales
but they can't be siloed
because there are in fact,
effects that cross scales
that have to be taken into account.
And what they then do is they
develop handshaking models
that are more localized
and connecting two...
Theoretically incommensurable models
and for local interactions.
And I'm wondering if you're
seeing that as, you know,
advancing the point you're
making about the way siloing
helps this or as a problem
for what you wanted to say?
- Yeah, I guess like...
Yeah, if the length scales
are not immensely different,
so here we're talking about yeah,
string scale with respect to bacterium
is a gigantic difference of length scales.
Indeed, it's not a clear cutoff.
It's not if it's 10
times big in length scale
it's gonna be zero and
if it's like nine times,
it's gonna be completely different.
But yeah, their normalization group
does explain when you have...
Yeah, yeah this supports why
we get renormalizable
theories at low scale.
Of course, the effective field theories
are also immensely successful at,
yeah, describing things
and they can be predictive.
- Yeah, no, I just wanted
to add to Joe Raz's point
that even in phenomenology
with other physical systems,
like if you look at
cosmic scales and stuff,
the scales are actually connected
but the challenge is
bridging those scales,
say computationally or observationally
and putting together a picture
that includes the crosstalk
between scales, right?
So, far it's been kind
of modeling limitations
that have really prevented us to...
So they seem siloed only because
we don't have the description
to appropriately connect cause
and effect across scales.
Because I mean it's a...
- So gravity is a bit different after all.
Like the field theories
we have for gravity
are not normalizable, very normalizable,
except for string theory anyways.
- String theories, right?
Yeah.
- String theory is more than
generalizable, it's finite.
Anyways, sorry...
So I'm sorry, I forgot what you asked.
- Coupling of scales.
- Right so yeah but ultimately
for all those simulations
and that bridging of length scales,
you're talking about ultimately
you don't need quantum
gravity to do that, right?
So at the very least there
is a decoupling between...
So there are different length scales-
- In a meta sense, yes.
- So like even we think of
earth and the solar system
as being on different length scales,
but like our planet is...
Has only length scale of
thousands of kilometers
and the sun is on millions of kilometers
just the three scales of magnitude.
Whereas with the plank
scale it's a lot more.
Yeah, that's what I was trying to say
that they, yeah, the normalizable
erases those effects about non...
Yeah, relevant operators.
- Any other questions?
- A short comment for you in
the defense of miasma theory
because not...
But the thing is, is
first it wasn't medieval.
It didn't end in medieval times
because Johns Hopkins was built
on the assumptions of miasma theory.
But the link between the
theories is that, for me,
is that miasma theory
was pointing to smells
that, you know, got from
sick people, you know?
- I see.
- But the smells were made by bacteria.
So nobody ask, you know,
what is smell coming from?
If they would ask that they could end up
looking at bacteria, which
we discovered 200 years
before the were linked to disease.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- It's a much more
complex story, much more-
- No, no a good point that, you know,
the questions that we
ask always sort of shape
the connections between cause and effect
that we can make, right?
So if we don't ask the right questions,
we never quite come to the causes, right?
Tim?
- Yeah so, I know most of this
was about biology and cells.
I got stuck at the first slide.
So I just...
I'm trying to understand
how you're thinking about,
you said, "Oh I've got these four forces
and these preserve information
and gravity doesn't."
Newtonian gravity does, GR does.
Preserving information is just code
for being bi-deterministic.
So the standard theories
you have of gravity,
certainly preserve information.
So I don't understand why
you're picking gravity out
and saying it has a problem.
In fact, standard quantum mechanics
is really a collapse theory
and collapse kills information.
So I would actually put the way
you read it in the textbook,
the first three don't preserve information
and the last one does.
So I just don't even understand
how you're thinking about any of this.
- [Moderator] I think you were referring
to black holes in particular, right?
- I was referring to black holes
actually in the context
of general relativity,
there's no-hair theorem for black holes.
That has been taken as as like-
- But that's not-
- Wait, wait, wait, wait
to get to the other points
of what are more interesting
that you brought up.
So, actually the reason why
we say that those three QFTs
present information is also the point
you are bringing up the other
day that they're unitary,
so they explicitly present
information in that sense.
There is...
They are quantum mechanical
so the moment you do an observation,
yeah you have jumpers of wave functions,
you could interpret it in a different way.
The standard way would be
based on, in physics at least,
it would be based on
whether the unitary or not.
And about quantum gravity,
not just gravity now,
there's this infinite information paradox.
Yeah, by Hawking and in his
calculation he was seeing
that indeed there are no
correlations the radiations...
Which brings us back to your first comment
that like yeah, he wasn't
seeing any correlations.
The radiation emitted from
the black hole was thermal.
- Right.
- And he was having a lot of ideas
of how to try to fix those things.
The baby universe idea
was actually also his
but somehow the society
moved away from that
and then he himself started thinking
about what information
is stored at infinity.
Those papers he published with Stronger
a little before he died.
Yeah, so to come back to-
- Let me just make,
again, I don't want to
get to just make a comment
'cause people say this stuff all the time,
I don't think it's correct.
The no-hair theorems don't show
what you just claimed they show.
- Okay.
- Because they show that asymptotically,
if you have an actual star that collapses,
there will be traces of that
even at the boundary in the geometry.
In the same way, as your ashes
after you've burned your manuscript,
there are traces there, right?
The no-hair theorem doesn't say
that different initial states
go to the same final state,
even exterior but that
they asymptote to it.
So it's not really relevant to
this question of information.
I mean, I just think there's
a lot of confusion in this.
- So, I think you're
getting at that theory
that Stronger and Hawking published
about the celestial holography
and whether information
is stored at infinity.
I think that's what I'm getting
by your use of asymptotically.
- Yeah, no.
- [Moderator] Yeah,
yeah, no I think, yeah.
Yakum, you had a question.
- Yeah, but it might be...
I don't know if I want
to ask this question.
Maybe it's too early but
the question would be-
- Quick.
- Yeah, okay about the fact
that you want to generalize
and that you think that
the universe has axiom.
So why would you believe
that in the first place?
That the universe has
axioms and is axiomisable?
But maybe that's something for
a coffee break, I'm not sure.
- Yeah, no.
- Maybe people will start
throwing stones at me now,
I don't know.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, exactly, maybe cocktails even.
I agree with Brandon, right?
Coffee is not gonna do it for that one.
(everyone laughs)
- Don't ruin my coffee.
- I was using the term axioms
as a theory of everything
that explains all the fundamental
interactions and particles,
that's how I was using it.
Yeah, I guess since we see
theories that do generalize,
there's a belief that
there is something that...
Something common.
It's not, we're not in
the (indistinct) zone,
there is a law that we need to find out.
Not all laws are are fair game,
otherwise we would be in trouble.
Yeah.
- [Moderator] Great,
thanks very much, Stathis.
Thank you very much for a-
- Thanks. (audience applauds)
- [Moderator] Very
interesting presentation.